could you tell me about my mother please  we went everywhere together we were  inseparable skating on the riverbanks  dancing in the courtyard taking panties  up the houses but nobody was looking  I'd stay up all night in the flower  gardens talking and talking dreaming  about you yeah your mother's room  oh it's beautiful  this is my mother's butt and now yours  if you like  you remind me so much of her your mother  and I used to dance and my family wonder  why I've gone see your world this much  more slowly but our you'll be back  before you even notice that you  disappear  if you want to go back I'm not leaving  without the key and that that I quite  understand you can tell them can you  keep a secret